Hello and welcome to another episode of Rawkode
live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today we are going to be taking a
look at Pixie,
an open source tool for zero code instrumentation
of Kubernetes and your applications.
Before we take a look at that, there's
a little bit of housekeeping.
If you're not already subscribed to the YouTube
channel, I would encourage you to do so
now. Click subscribe and click the bell and
you will get notifications for all new episodes
of Rawkode live. Every week, I try to
explore as much of the cloud native ecosystem
as I can to bring you all of
the knowledge that you need to learn this
mess together.
And of course, we have a Discord server
available at Rawkode.chat.
If you wanna chat about Kubernetes, Cloud Native,
Rock Music or anything in between, come and
say hello. There's over 400 of us in
there now chatting away, having some fun.
Alright. Now, Pixie. In order to guide me
today, I'm joined by Natalie Serino from the
Pixie team. Hi there, Natalie. How are you?
Hey there. Doing great. How are you doing?
I'm very well. Thank you. Thank you for
joining us today. Can you just take a
few moments to share a little bit about
you and tell us who you are?
Yeah, totally. So
I am Natalie. I am a engineer on
the Pixie team.
Pixie
was acquired by New Relic in December and
so part of that company as well.
Before I came in the observability space, was
in the data space. So I guess that's
my little micro background and wanted to go
look for interesting data problems and I think
observability is a great example of one of
them.
Awesome. Yeah. There's there's definitely a lot of
data in the observability space especially as we
are starting to see more teams and organizations,
adult micro services with distributed tracing, like that
data is growing at crazy rates.
Yep. And like most data problems like, you
know, collecting the data is half the battle.
Yes.
Definitely.
And I'm I mean, let let's just start
talking about Pixie because I'm I'm really curious.
This has been one of the the most
requested technologies that I've been asked to cover
on this show. So I'm really excited to
bring this to people but it says here
on the website that we can instantly debug
applications on Kubernetes
and it doesn't require any instrumentation.
Do you wanna share a little bit about
that?
Yeah. I think that that's a really exciting
thing about Pixie that drew me to working
on the project in the first place because
I think that,
you know, historically,
there's been a lot of challenge with collecting
the data that we need in order to
successfully debug our production systems. And, you know,
what,
myself and the other members of Pixie found
in the past is that debugging your developer
environment is one thing, but debugging a production
environment is completely different.
And,
it feels like you're riding blind a lot
of the time, and we'd like to have
access to a lot of the same data
that we can easily get in our development
environments.
So I think that was kind of one
of the initial inspirations for it. And,
you know, this coincided
with
the,
you know, kind of popularization
and,
you know, adoption of eBPF in the Linux
kernel,
popularized,
like, in large part by Brendan Gregg who
has done a lot of amazing work in
the space. And
I guess just a little bit of background
on eBPF for people who, you know, aren't
as familiar with it.
It's basically
like, I think of it as a way
of registering hooks in the Linux kernel.
So anytime you open a file or anytime
you drop a packet or anytime,
you know, you receive a request on the
network, all these things you can put hooks
into and,
you know, tell the kernel to run a
function that you register with it. And that
actually
has huge, huge
benefits for things like security where you can
use it to put in really,
advanced in networking rules, but it also has
great implications for observability because
it basically gives us a handle on the
total state of your system without having to
put any code changes
or anything like that in to collect that
data. And we found that we can collect
a very rich set of data and we're
only scratching the surface.
We can use eBPF and Pixie to automatically
collect
full body requests made by,
you know, anywhere in your cluster,
you know, DNS
stuff, you know, MySQL,
Postgres,
and also things like network statistics and system
metrics. So we're really excited because
in, you know, basically what you'll see as
a pretty quick deploy process, you basically get
all that information immediately when it would have
previously taken months to get.
Yeah. Definitely. I think EBPF is just one
of the coolest technologies that we have right
now. There's there's so much cool stuff you
can do with it with regards to these
probes and the kernel hooks and and such.
I was I had never really thought about
it before as an application for collecting telemetry
but it's like without having to modify my
code but you know what now that I've
seen Pixie's website and I've heard you talk
about it like I'm like yeah, like why
why wouldn't we do this because you know,
the kernel is our our application is an
interface to the kernel like we
already know what's happening at some level within
that stack.
There's metrics from it and other things.
Okay.
Also, there's
I should really just show my screen. Shouldn't
I? Let's pop that up. There
was a oh, no. It's gone. There was
a banner at the top that says that
Pixie is moving to the CNCF as well.
So the Pixie is completely open source and
soon to be a CNCF sandbox project. Project.
Is is that correct?
Yeah. I'm really glad you brought that up
because it's, you know, recent news and we're
so excited about it.
So I guess just like little historically, Pixie
was originally a startup. And then when,
you know, we decided to partner up with
New Relic and, you know, join them,
you know, we were really excited that they
shared our vision of reaching even more developers
than before. And, you know, in this space,
you know,
open source is really important for people. People
really like to build on top of open
source stacks. And so we were really, really
happy that they shared our vision of turning
Pixie into an open source project.
And
with the CNCF,
with the amazing caliber of projects that they
have in, you know, in the CNCF, we're
so thrilled to be a sandbox project that
was,
you know, made a formal few weeks ago
that they've decided to accept us as a
sandbox project. And so we're really excited to
have, you know, like, tighter relationships with those
projects and also just show our commitment to
remaining a truly open source project.
Pixie is entirely open source and licensed under
Apache two point o, and it's gonna stay
that way. So that's our commitment to our
users that that is what the situation is
gonna be going forward, and joining CNCF is
a good way to show that.
Alright. So everyone watching today
has the opportunity to learn Pixie, use it
in their own applications and never have to
pay a dime, which I think is pretty
sweet. And they don't have to use New
Relic just to clarify, right? Like you can
use Pixie without using New Relic at all.
So New Relic are essentially just
helping
Pixie grow but not integrate and enter product
or something like that? Like Pixie is its
own thing, right? Yeah. It's a good question.
So,
you know, if you if you were wanting
to use the purely open source, like self
hosted version of Pixie, all of those components
are available and we have docs on how
to get started with that. We also have
a version of Pixie where the cloud component
is hosted,
by us,
with a very,
very generous free tier where,
you know, if you want to do a
little bit less legwork in getting started,
then you can, you know, have us host
the cloud side of that.
Now New Relic has really awesome integrations with
Pixie, but Pixie is its own thing. So
you don't have to use New Relic to
use Pixie.
Awesome.
Okay. Should we get this installed into our
cluster?
Let's do it.
Alright. Now I can already tell from the
homepage here, we have every developer's favorite
curl bash. Is that the way that you
must install today?
Yeah. I mean, if you go into our
docs, you can see that there's other ways
to install as well for people that prefer
other modes.
But I think that
yeah. If you go to install schemes,
and you can just click on the, like,
a parent of that, like, schemes.
Oh, yeah. Never mind. It just did what?
But we have helm based and, you know,
YAML based installs as well for people who
prefer to go that route.
But I think that for the purposes of
this, I think that I recommend
starting with the bash based install. Yep. You
don't have to convince me. I'm so Okay.
So, this is obviously running on my local
machine. So, is this going to install Pixie
CLI to my machine? Is it gonna install
something to my Kubernetes cluster? What should I
expect here?
So what this is gonna do is install
the Pixie CLI locally to you and you're
going to
authenticate
with
oh, I,
we use Gmail or G Suite for authentication
in this version, so hopefully that's okay and
you have a personal Gmail account you can
link it to. Yeah. No problem.
So it's gonna install a CLI and then
basically ask you to sign up. Oh, you'll
wanna sign up actually
unless you've logged in before.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Good catch.
Yeah. Yeah.
Sign up with Google.
And then if that's a good Gmail for
you, then that's great for us.
Oh, maybe you have actually signed up in
the past.
Oh, no. Okay. Sorry. It just lagged. Okay.
It looks like it worked.
Okay. Sweet. Yeah. It may be okay. And
so, you know, basically, the Pixie CLI has
a lot of stuff that you can do.
The first thing that most people do is
install Pixie itself onto their Kubernetes cluster.
But before you do that,
I just wanna point out that we have,
like, two modes that we can install Pixie.
One way that,
you know,
is kind of the default and it uses,
persistent volumes
and PebbleDB is the backing store. But we
also support
a version that
uses the etcd operator, which doesn't require persistent
volumes.
So I think that for this cluster, what
we might wanna do is use that version
of Pixie.
Yeah. Okay. Happy with that.
Because I think that you mentioned that, the
persistent volumes,
like, may need to be set up. So,
let's just skip that and just go straight
to it. Yeah. I'm okay with that. This
is a a bare metal cluster, and I
do provision Rooka on them, but it's definitely
not something I'm happy to try and debug
live. So if there's a a no PVC
option, I'm definitely gonna gonna grab that.
Yeah. So if you do PX deploy dash
space dash h, then we can see the
deploy option. So what you have there is
all the options for,
you know, the PX command. So we can
see that dash o gives us use etcd
operator. Operator,
and that's the one that we are, you
know, looking at right now.
So let's see what happens.
Okay. So that's all I need. It's just
that flag to see who's the operator. Nothing
else is required? Yeah. It's gonna try to
deploy to your local Kubernetes context, your current
context. And so if you need to switch
context, then,
you know, that would be something good to
do.
Nope. I am on my Pixie one
three node cluster,
so we should be okay.
Okay. Great.
Okay. So this is okay because this is
a bare metal Kubernetes cluster, which should still
work even though it's giving you a scary
warning message, and we like to ride dangerously.
Alright. So just say yes. Life on the
edge.
Life on the edge. Quite literally because Pixie
actually collects and stores all of its data
on the edge rather than shipping it off
to a cloud.
Ah, okay.
So it's creating a namespace,
looking for a previous installation, I guess, and
cleaning up. Now we're getting some secrets and
some config maps.
I guess this is just a good
You know, Pixie is like a Kubernetes it's
a set of Kubernetes services, basically. And so
we have some dependencies,
like, you know, we'll be deploying NATs
and etcd, and then also
deploying
the,
what we call the Vizier PEM nodes, which
are the ones that are responsible for
actually deploying the eBPF probes and collecting the
data that you can query.
Okay.
Well, I'm a big fan of NAT, so
that's cool. So I'm assuming we've got collectors
that are publishing messages to NATs and then
are those being consumed by some sort of
workers?
I'm just gonna guess how your software works
now. Sorry. Yeah. I know. It's a great
question. We're also really big fans of NATs
as well. So,
basically,
what we have is,
a PEM node will be deployed on or
a PEM pod will be deployed on every
node in your cluster,
unless you have something like a taint that
blocks it.
And so these PEM nodes are going to
deploy the BPF probes and start collecting data
and storing it, you know, within the PEM.
So the data is actually not being sent
over NATs. It's actually just being stored on
the node that it exists on because
we really wanna be a low burden to
the network and just kind of keep data
where it's collected. That's one of the things
that, you know, we're trying to do.
So,
but, you know, we use NATs for lots
of different stuff, like communicating
the current state of the PEMs and make
sure they're healthy or
sending messages about Kubernetes
metadata that, you know, the PEMs need to
be aware of when a query is run.
Alright. Okay.
Well, it looks like everything has deployed and
now we're waiting for those PEMs slash
Kelvin.
Yeah. So basically,
at this point, all of the prerequisites
for the cluster have been deployed and now
the PEMs themselves are being launched.
Kelvin is
you can kind of think of it as
like
the collector node because when you run a
query, you may be asking about data on
multiple PEMs at once and they need a
common place to send it to for the
reduced stage of the query if you think
of it that way. So Kelvin fulfills that
role.
Okay.
We have a question on the chat which
I'll throw up for you. But Noel is
asking what is Sentry?
Oh, yeah. That's a good question. So, Sentry
is,
something that allows us to track errors
in,
Pixie when people run into problems.
I think that,
you know,
that is something that,
is,
going to be optional.
So
people can kind of choose if they want
to let us know when they're having a
some kind of crash.
Yeah. I think I've I've used Sentry before.
It's like an SDK you can bundle in
your application which catches exceptions and then throws
them off to the Sentry thing and can
keep an eye on them and see how
often they know recur and such like that.
It's a it's a really cool open source
tool as well, I believe.
Yeah. It's it's a really good way of
finding out,
you know, what your problems are and what
problems your users are running into that you
may not be hearing about.
Yeah. In a former life, I used to
work on Android and iOS apps, and we
always bundled Sentry. And it's it's overwhelming in
that context when you've got enough users. So
I don't recommend it for that use case.
So it looks like it's successfully deployed, which
is great. The demo gods are with us.
So I don't know before we use the
UI if you wanna try running a query
in the CLI just to kinda show off
the fact that you don't even have to
leave the terminal.
So
just just to clarify then, right, like that
Yeah. That PX deploy dash o
Mhmm. Has done everything. We're we're now collecting
telemetry from this cluster.
Yeah, that's right. Previously where you might have
had to spend quite a bit of time
investing in the
data collection,
it's basically been entirely done for us in
this process.
You can always extend the data that we
collect. We have the ability for you to
deploy custom BPF traces and things like that.
But,
you know, right out of the box, you
get access to all of your HTTP
requests, your c SQL requests,
your CPU usage,
how loaded is your network,
you know, just with this one command.
Okay.
So you suggested we can do something on
the command line here to to actually introspect
that in some way. So
Why don't you do PX script list and
then we can kinda see, like, if anything
pops out to you as something that's interesting.
There's a lot of results here, but
I can also recommend a few if that's
easier. But,
you know, I think a good one to
maybe a really simple one to do is
p x namespaces.
Just kinda tells you what are the namespaces
that you have running.
So if you do
p x run, you can just do space
p x slash namespaces to execute that script.
Right.
We can kinda see this is a very
simple script. There's a lot fancier ones, but
just didn't wanna overwhelm people all at once
in the CLI.
So we can see the different namespaces that
we have, the number of pods and services
that they have, as well as the resource
consumption that we're seeing aggregated by namespace.
Okay. So yeah.
So I
just want to make sure I understand this
correctly. So PX run allows me to run
Pixie scripts. What what what is a Pixie
script look like? Can we can we look
at what that that was?
I'm so glad you asked. That's
one of my favorite parts about Pixie actually
because
we made it a 100%
scriptable platform.
And what that means is that the scripts
that you write or the scripts that we
have provided right out of the box are
the thing that you use across the UI,
the CLI, and our client APIs.
So it's one consistent way to run queries.
Pixie's language is
Pythonic,
so we use Python syntax so that people
don't have to learn a brand new syntax.
And we were really inspired by,
Pandas, if anyone's familiar with that, which allows
people to,
you know, it's a really great tool for,
cleaning up, preparing, and analyzing your datasets in
Python.
And we found that all the stuff it
does, we also need to do those things.
So we decided to just follow their API
rather than reinvent the wheel. So when you
look at it, it will kinda just look
like Python code.
If you wanna look at scripts,
one way that you could do that is
you could clone our repo, and I can
show you where the scripts are in there.
Or we could just open the UI and
then we can always inspect the script that's
generating a given view.
Okay. So if I click this link here
that it gave me after I ran.
Okay.
Let's let's clarify the most important thing we'll
clarify today. The command pronunciation.
Is it Pixie or Pix or PX?
I don't know, man. I mean, I kinda
like to watch Flame Wars, so maybe we
should explicitly not weigh in here and then
see if people develop a strong consensus.
But I I will admit I say PX.
PX. Okay. I'll I'll go with PX. I'll
I'll I'll go with you, but the audience
can feel free to bring in their own
flavor.
So let's see if I can actually log
in after that little
maybe full pie. Yeah. Flash.
It worked. Okay. Cool.
Yeah. So as you can see, when you
run a script in the CLI, you have
the ability to click and just access that
same exact thing in the UI if you
wanna send it to someone or something like
that.
Okay. So
so many questions.
So there's no data leaving
my servers to go to the
to go to your servers, right? Is this
querying my cluster?
I I how does the data transfer work
here? Yeah. Let's dive in. So we want
to store data on the edge that it
was collected.
We think that that is a really good
way to lower the network utilization because in
your production system, you don't wanna be maxing
out your network cards sending out telemetry data.
So that's a really good thing from a
system perspective, but it's also a good thing
from a privacy perspective because
we Pixie
pedal. That's funny.
Because, you know, we recognize that, you know,
telemetry data is sensitive. And when you keep
it where it was collected, that's a way
of adding another layer of privacy.
So
we have two modes with Pixie.
The first mode,
basically
uses Pixie Cloud as a proxy
so that when the UI has a query,
it proxies it through Pixie Cloud. And in
this form, the data is always traveled entirely
encrypted,
never persisted on the Pixie Cloud side of
things. But for people who would prefer
that this not be the case, we also
have data isolation mode, which basically says when
I'm running the UI,
I will actually query my cluster directly,
and there won't be any proxying.
This can have downsides because you always need
to be able to access the Kubernetes cluster
when you use the UI.
And so we think that,
you know, both modes are valid, but we
default to the pass through mode because of
the user experience it provides while still maintaining
the promise that we don't persist it anywhere
else.
Okay. Perfect.
We have another question in the chat, which
doesn't really is very specific to this, but
Vikram is asking, can we run the UI
on our own cluster or local host? Is
that an option?
Yeah. It is. So if you do the
fully self hosted version of Pixie
and you can, you know, just check out
the docs for how to run that, then
you would be basically running it yourself.
Got it. Okay. So this is the same
representation of what we got on the command
line here where we have a kind of
TLDR on our namespaces and what's running in
them. Then we've got telemetry
showing us disk throughput
and
yeah. Desk throughput and network stats. I'm sure
there was some network there.
Mhmm. Maybe. There might not be. Maybe I
should change the script. But I wanted to
start really simple because
I think this is a good before we
dive into kind of the rest of what's
going on here, I wanted to just show
the script for this view.
So if you scroll up and then you
click that little bit, that little, like, cursor,
yeah, that editor,
basically, you can see the code that produces
the script.
So,
basically, you can see the namespaces for cluster
function will produce the table that is the
top one. It's basically getting a list of
namespaces
in the current cluster.
And then
one,
the next function is producing an overview of
the resource consumption by namespace. So these are
the two views that we're computing.
Okay.
Yeah. It does just look like Python code.
Yeah. And that that is that is by
design because
we're making this for developers and we,
as developers, want our observability pipelines to be
more like writing code.
Okay. But for people that don't wanna mess
with the custom scripts, you don't have to.
We have a ton of scripts that ship
right off the bat, but we do find
that, you know, power users who really like
to get into it do enjoy writing custom
queries and drilling into stuff that's like especially
important for them in particular.
Well, yeah, I guess because, you know, Pixie
understands what data is being collected that you
can already produce all these scripts up front
that just represent that in the best possible
way. So
it kind of makes a lot of sense.
What's a VED spec?
Is this just a display we've got here?
Exactly. It's just telling you how you wanna
lay out the results of the query.
So we have more than just tables as
we'll see if, you know, we go into
the cluster view, for example.
But
with the VisBag, you can specify what type
of visualization you want. So I recommend switching
to PX cluster because that's kind of like
the starting view that we show to people
in most cases.
And I can walk you through what we're
seeing here if that would be helpful.
Yes. I see a graph, but I'm not
entirely sure what the graph is representing.
Yeah. So this is our service map.
So it looks like we're detecting services on
your cluster, but we're not necessarily
detecting
the services
talking to each other.
And that can happen when a pod isn't
part of a service and it's talking to
things. So this is it.
You know, it may not be the prettiest
graph, but it, you know, we we often
see results like that.
If you scroll down,
you can see the list of nodes.
And if you look at the node name,
you can actually
click that link and actually be taken to
a view about that node.
So we really wanna make a really easy
drill down experience for people.
And so we have these hyperlinks embedded in
our tables in multiple places where you can
just click a link to see more about
that entity.
So here we see the pods that are
running on this node,
the CPU usage of the node, and other
things like the traffic and the bytes.
Nice.
I like it when you get shared cursors
like this across panels and graphs.
Yeah. Because some the shared lining it up
like these two things happen the same.
So this is a bespoke UI. Right? This
is this is written just for Pixie. Like,
do people have the option to use Grafana
if they want or would you encourage using
the the Pixie dashboards?
You know, it depends on, you know, your
unique situation. So we do have a Grafana
plugin that's available and open source.
So if that's the environment you're comfortable in,
you can configure Pixie as a data source
and use it to help build your Grafana
dashboards.
But if you
kind of just want a super easy
like, you don't have to, you know, set
that up or whatnot. You can also just
use the UI and, you
know, we think that either one is a
good thing to do. But the flame graph,
yeah, I'm glad that's being called out. So,
yeah, that's only a new feature we're pretty
excited about because,
you know, this kind of data can be
kind of hard to get in most cases.
So,
we're basically running profilers
on your,
you know, various nodes and seeing like where
is the time being spent.
And,
we have heard that people really like that
because it can help isolate bottlenecks.
Yeah. That's pretty nice. I like that.
I wanna see what other scripts we've got.
Oh. Oh. I just zoomed. That was cool.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Oh, that is nice.
There we go.
I kinda wish I had like planned ahead
and stuck a few thousand workloads or something
on this cluster to kinda see more but
we're still getting a lot, mean considering this
is a really vanilla Kubernetes cluster that's just
running the control plane Rawk and Cilium. We're
already getting a whole wealth of information out
of this immediately which is pretty nice.
We have a question from Noel if you
want to tackle that and Noel is asking
does this profiling have an impact on
you know, our CPU and memory and such?
Yeah. For sure. So, you
know, with
these types of tools, we realized that it's
so important for us to take as minimal
of a footprint as possible while still providing
really rich geometry.
Because,
you know, I take it very seriously what
runs on my production cluster, and I don't
want that to be something that in a
bad time is eating, like, 50% of my
CPU or something like that. And so with
that being said,
we
we target that Pixie will use under 2%
of the CPU
of each of the nodes. But,
you know, just for some buffer room and
practice, we say that it should say under
5%. But we're always looking to drive that
down.
Okay.
Can we confirm that through the what's being
logged?
Oh, hell hell yeah. Definitely. So if you
wanna go click on the PL Vizier pen
pod in this you don't even have to
exit out of this view. You see that
PL Vizier PEM pod? Yep. So let's let's
take a look and see if we're living
up to that. If not, I can file
some bugs.
So Oh, wow. That's the CPU usage for
this pod and it looks like we are
seeing under 2%. So that 5%
qualification, I guess, wasn't necessary here.
Yeah. So we can actually see yeah. We've
got all the major stats on this pod
and what what is happening.
Are these functions and syscalls? Pod two.
Oh, sorry. I think I missed that. Are
these the functions or syscalls that that application's
calling?
You know, so for compiled languages, we're actually
able to get the function names.
And so if you're running a c plus
plus c or go
application for example, we're actually able to extract
out the functions themselves and how much time
that they are each causing, not just the
system calls.
Okay.
So you'll see a lot of C plus
plus in there because that's what the PEM
is made on.
That's pretty
magic.
I like that. I wanna look at something
else now. Can I just change pod?
Yeah. You can change pod for sure. You
know, you can
also like as you were doing browse the
scripts and see what is up with those.
Yeah. We can definitely take a look at
more scripts. So this this is our Cilium
pod which you know handles all of the
networking
because he's making HTTP requests.
I'm curious then, like does
Pixie understand
all the major protocols like HTTP,
gRPC,
Kafka or
does
it does it not care about that stuff?
Yeah.
You know anything that uses HTTP
you know, will automatically be traced.
So sometimes those protocols will use HTTP, you
know, kind of underneath the hood. But we
also do support, like, many different protocols in
addition to that.
And we have a list on our doc
page, but I can just rattle off some
examples.
We support MySQL,
Cassandra,
Postgres.
We support
DNS.
We support encrypted encrypted HTTP traffic in addition
to unencrypted HTTP traffic.
We have
support for other ones, and I'm just blanking
a little bit. But if you wanna just
pull up the docs, we can take a
look. Yeah. Yeah. Definitely. I'd only expect you
to remember all this off the top of
your head.
So if you go to supported protocols at
the very top of the if you scroll
up Yeah. Supported protocols. Yeah.
Yeah. Oh, I forgot Redis. Redis is a
big one.
And we're always looking to add more protocols.
So Kafka is a very interesting one.
Okay. So at my applications, all my cluster
where Pixie is deployed is used in h
t t p, h t p two, g
r p c d n s, etcetera,
telemetry is automatically gonna be collected for me.
Mhmm. And we'll also ship Pixie with views
that query that data and present it to
you in an easy to consume fashion.
So
support that protocol, like, also includes like,
you know, scripts that you can easily access.
Okay. That is very very cool.
Okay. So we can see the processes on
our pod.
Network stats.
Yeah. I really be able to see stuff
by container too.
Even just seeing the request being made, we've
got the p 99 here. That's just invaluable
information when you're debugging microservices.
Very, Yeah. And I don't know how easy
this is to discover, but if you see
those little, like, white tick marks, if you
click,
like, let's say, like, the one in the
middle of the bar in the latency p
99 section.
So if you just click another one Oh.
Oh, is it? Yeah. If you just click
that,
it switches everything
to p 50. So now you can see
all the fifties. So you can drill down
into p 50, p 90 and p 99
in this column. And you can sort as
well.
Okay. Got it.
And then if I expand it, I can
just actually see those values here too.
Yeah. That's useful when you have a lot
columns in the result table and you kind
of want to look into a particular record
in detail.
Okay.
That was impressive. I really liked that.
Let's take a look
at another script. Do you want me to
pick one or is there something you'd like
to take a look at here?
Let's do NetFlow graph. I really always enjoy
that one.
And you're gonna have to put a namespace
in. So
if you want, you can put in PL
because I know that one exists, or you
can put in one of the namespaces you're
interested in looking at.
The type one is not, like, giving me
a If you click on the if you
click on namespace to filter on.
Is it
if you so you see where it has
the text namespace to filter on? Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Alright. Okay.
Yeah. You just type p l or or
default. Default works too.
There we go.
So it's a little bit overwhelming, but what
we're seeing is
a map of the network traffic that we
have in this namespace.
And we try to resolve as best we
can all the places that
your different pods are talking to.
Okay. So we can actually see which of
the Pixie
pods are communicating with one another
through all these lanes. What's the difference between
the blue and the gray kinda node representation?
Mhmm.
Yeah. So,
basically,
the blue is more like,
it's more considered like remote,
I guess.
So the non blue is the pod in
your namespace, and then the blue is anyone
else that it's talking to because we have
that namespace filter in here and that filters
the gray ones.
But we know that these pods may be
talking to destinations
outside the namespace or even outside the cluster
and we wanna still represent that information.
Okay.
What happens if I click enable hierarchy down
here?
Let's see.
Sometimes that can be a nicer representation.
Oh, I can zoom.
Mhmm. Mhmm. And drag it around. Yep.
So now we can see more clusters of
behavior.
There we go. That's a bit better.
Mhmm. Yeah. The other one was a little
a little extra.
That's cool.
I mean, how does it get like the
the domain names if it's encrypted traffic?
Or is that all it gets? It doesn't
get paths and such?
I'm not actually sure. Well, we Pixie has
access to be able to trace the the
encrypted traffic when it's unencrypted
by the system. So we can actually give
you a full request
because we're collecting it in the place that
it is already encrypt unencrypted, if that makes
sense. Yes. Okay.
There's
a loud siren. Hopefully you can hear that.
Okay.
So then we've got
so this is just all the requests. Okay.
So we can see where where the source
was, where the destination was
and we've got bytes sent and bytes received.
Yeah. This can often be a pretty eye
opening view for our users and
it
can produce some unexpected results sometimes. We often
hear things like, wait, those two things shouldn't
be talking.
What the heck?
Yeah. Yeah.
It's just good to get in, like these
are things I think that are so easy
to overlook in your clusters that you just,
you know, you don't have observability in them
or you just forget or you're gonna do
it later and like
this took all this took me all of
what ten seconds to deploy and get this.
So yeah. Very
very cool. EPPF is so cool.
Really it's really cool stuff and we're really
excited to be building this because,
you know, as developers, we're trying to build
the thing that we ourselves want.
Oh, so this funcs is basically, like,
trying to help the user if they wanna
compose their own queries and they wanna know
what functions are available.
Now,
this also exists in our docs and I
would argue it may be more easily consumable
in the docs, but,
just an example of the type of kind
of like helper view that we can also
provide in addition to the more typical views.
Yeah. I I kind of accidentally clicked on
that. Wasn't something I intended to click on
so
Oh, okay.
But I was getting when I clicked on
it, I like, oh, wonder what this is
and then I had no idea so I'm
glad you explained it.
Alright. Let's take a look at maybe two
more and then we can see what other
functionality we we have available here.
Maybe HTTP data could be a good one.
HTTP.
I think that a lot of times, like,
it's good to see the computer results, but
I also just love to see the raw
data sometimes.
And this is a very raw view. It's
a little I would expand a row because
it's it's very wide.
But this is the type of information that
we're able to collect. We're able to collect
the request and response body, the headers, the
time, the pod that it happened on,
the path.
Yeah. So we've got full visibility and to
each of the HTTP requests that were captured
by Pixie. Right.
Right. Okay. And each protocol will have its
own kind of equivalent view of just looking
at the raw data.
So I'm curious, like, you know, we're using
Pixie scripts that are just pre canned for
us. Like, if I wanted to be able
to see,
you know, because this is, you know, HTTP
aware,
it possible for me to see all the
four hundreds or five hundreds and be able
to keep
a track of things that are maybe broken
in my custom? Oh,
definitely.
So
we do capture the codes and that's,
you know, one of the ways that we
produce
plots of, like, errors per service and things
like that.
Maybe it would be good to
busy response status, c 200. So you can
write a pixel script that, you know, aggregates
on response status or,
you know, does all the things with the
code or counts the number of things that
are not success.
We do that in a lot of our
scripts. And so, like, any of these parameters
that you see, like, you can write scripts
to analyze. And we hope that the default
scripts we provide
cover,
you know, maybe, like, all the common cases
so that people don't have to do unnecessary
work. But if there's something special you wanna
ask, then,
you know, this type of data you can
just query out.
Okay.
So do you want to do something with
that or do you want to take a
look at one more script and then move
on to that? What's your preference?
I don't know. Both are pretty good.
Why don't we edit this script and just
make it only show errors?
Alright. Okay. So we So let's go to
the pixel script.
So sorry. Are you saying is it pixel
script?
PixelScript.
Yeah. You can say PixieScript too. Either one.
But, it's technically PixelScript.
PXL
is how it's spelled. Gotcha. Okay. Yeah.
I think it'll be fun to make a
little modification to this to this script.
So, basically, what this script is doing is
it's pulling the HTTP data,
and it's extracting a little bit more metadata
to show in the results because
we're able to resolve things like the namespace
and the node and the pod that each
request,
you know, handed on happened
on. And Mhmm. We're also dropping some columns
that we don't think are maybe that useful
to people.
So I'm assuming based on kinda what I
see that there's probably like a d f
filter. Is that would that be right? You're
so close, but,
I'll tell you the,
I'll tell you the syntax. So you'll say
d and and you'll actually yeah. So d
f
equals
d f
and then we're gonna put brackets,
like square brackets.
And then this is basically pandas' way of
doing a filter and we're gonna put a
boolean
condition in here.
And that boolean condition will be used as
the filter condition.
Alright. So we'll have to, like, say status
greater than 400?
Yeah. But, the only modification that you you
got almost perfectly is that you'll do d
f dot resp status because we have to
specify which data frame, the column exists on.
So let's try running that
and see what we see.
And if you collapse you can collapse that
editor.
And now we'll see only
response statuses
that are Mhmm.
That's pretty nifty.
That's quite a lot. There's actually more than
I was expecting.
Yeah. Was
Alright. Now if I wanted to do like
an aggregate count of that, is that something
I can do in Pixelscript as well?
Oh yeah. Why don't we count it by
pod?
Alright. Okay. That sounds good.
I'm not gonna try and guess that. We're
gonna take off the d f. Head because
we don't need that. That's just basically saying
I only need a thousand records.
So I'll just walk you through. So you're
gonna d d f equals
Is that equals? It looks like a dash,
but maybe it's not. It's equals. Yeah. Okay.
Okay. And then you're gonna do d f
dot group by.
And No. It's it's just, like, just all
lowercase, no, underscore.
Okay.
And then you can do parens.
And then in, quotes in single quotes or
you could do double actually too. You'll do
pod. So, basically, this is saying we're we're
doing an aggregate that's gonna group by pod.
And then after that, after the last paren,
you're gonna do dot ag or
or a a g g.
Oh, ag. Correct. Okay.
And then in here, let's name the output
column. So let's just say, like, num underscore
errors.
It doesn't have to be in quotes. It
will just be, like, a key
Mhmm. Argument.
And then equals.
And then we're gonna have, like, a tuple
here.
And the first element of the tuple is
gonna be the input column.
So let's just say,
time underscore.
Doesn't really matter because we're doing account.
And then that will be in quotes.
And then comma
p x dot count. And so, basically, what
this and then that will yeah. It perfect.
So what that's basically saying and our docs
have more detailed information for how to compose
these queries if that was, like, completely alien.
It does it does follow the panda's API.
So there is a method to a method
to it, and then the docs basically tell
you about all of these different things you
can do so you can use them for
reference. But what this is saying is take
the pod column and then count the number
of errors per pod.
Okay. So will I hit run on this?
Yeah. Hit run.
We can
There we go. And it looks like
looks like
core DNS pods are a source of the
four four or 400 plus errors. So that
Yeah. Is something that we learned about your
cluster today. And that's within the last five
minutes?
Yeah. Is that Yeah. Okay. So you can
edit that to be bigger or smaller but,
know, we find that people tend to be
most interested in looking at
Oh, you made you made a mistake. We
need to work on the UX for this
a little bit. You actually have to do
negative because it's like a relative Yeah.
Of course. That makes sense.
But I I consider that to be kinda
our bad, not yours because it would be
very easy to make that mistake.
Okay.
So if someone else wants to learn how
to write Pexelscript,
I'm assuming they come into here.
We've got is it just reference?
Mhmm. So in operators,
for example,
you can click on ag and then see,
you know, that's what we did.
There we go.
Excellent.
Okay. Let's tackle a couple of questions and
then we'll we'll we'll see what else we
can do here. So Suresh is asking,
are there any improvements to go e b
p f observability done
and are they available open source?
I I guess the rest is asking whether
they know that the Pixie team is is
is working on Go eBPF and contributing there.
I'm not sure.
Yeah. So
I would say that we're more consumers of
eBPF
but,
you know, we hope that the stuff that
we provide
can be an example to other people who
wanna use eBPF
themselves.
And so you can look at our,
you know, repo and see what we do
as an inspiration for how you can also
incorporate it.
Okay.
And I'll just put up a comment from
Noel who's enjoying
my editor there on core DNS. I never
said I would produce a Philly working cluster.
Just just enough. That's as that's as good
as it gets.
It's not uncommon.
Well, Kubernetes is hard. So
alright. So we've got links to the Grafana
data source plugin here. Let's say we've got
some API documentation.
Oh, that go reference docs. Okay.
Yeah. So basically, we have client libraries if
you want to automate,
you know, pixies pixel scripts and use the
results to drive
CICD
stuff or, you know, we have a tutorial
to set up a Slack bot that can
ping you with results of,
you know, pixel scripts.
That can be, you know, a pretty quick
way to get alerts about what's happening in
your cluster if you, you know, wanted to
have been warned sooner about those four zero
four's or something like that.
Yeah. This I mean, I'm not gonna sit
and work through all of this documentation but
I think I'll be playing with this at
some point in the near future.
Now you mentioned alerts and there's a Slack
alert tutorial here.
Mhmm. Do you wanna work through this and
and take a look at the process involved
there, maybe setting up an alert? Like I
don't think we need to throw it to
Slack, we can use a HTTP banner or
something but
unless unless it's a Slack function, I'm I'm
not so for this tutorial, we've actually like,
you know, made all the boilerplate to like
Oh, okay. Do the Slack ping and stuff
like that.
So it might be easiest to do. So,
you know, we don't have to do it,
but this is just a quick way of
basically looking at 400
errors in your different services and just being
alerted to that.
I did it in a few minutes last
night and it's pretty easy.
So we can dive into this if you
think that that would be a good thing.
Well, yeah. I think, you know, what we've
shown so far let me just close that
one. Is,
you know, Pixie is already collecting a wealth
of information on my cluster and I haven't
done anything. Alright. So we've got a big
massive text there like I want this.
But now we've taking a look at the
scripts and there's loads there, know, we could
always take a look at a few more
just before we finish but there's always different
representations of things happening in my cluster.
We then modified a script and we're able
to actually get a count of the four
zero four as we see core DNS is
unhappy
and what I'm thinking is like, there's definitely
something I would want an alert from. I'd
want to know if
I have
I don't know, I don't know if we
can work out like the medians or what
the standard deviation is and stuff but I
probably want to learn something
with those four zero four's. So maybe if
we can put that together that would choose
a nice end to end example of what
what Pixie is bringing to my cluster.
Yeah. That sounds great. Why don't we just
work through that tutorial and
you know, just bang it out.
Okay.
So
do I need to do all the Slack
setup or can we just do the actual
Pixie bit and have it?
Let me let me do the
I'm gonna create a private channel in the
Pixie community repo
and
then we can use I'll create the slack
bot on my side. Okay.
Yeah. Because I just realized that they don't
have a Slack.
Right. Right. So,
like, let me just get that started
and I can
send that to you. And in the meantime,
you're gonna wanna track down the cluster ID
and create an API key in Pixie. So
why don't we parallelize this Mhmm. And you
can collect those pieces of information. And I
can help you find them if you have
trouble. Information and I can help you find
them if you have trouble. Okay. So should
I do the Pixie deploy just now? The
demo deploy?
I don't think that you have to but
Alright. Okay. I think that's just if people
wanna see more data but I don't think
that that's necessary.
Alright. Okay. That's deploying the Pixie Socks shop
demo. I guess that's a micro service thing.
Okay. Yeah. We're gonna have to make a
little modification to the pixel script
because it filters on that particular namespace, but
we can just quickly modify that. That won't
be a problem.
Okay. Sounds good. So I'm running
Pixie get Visiers and
I have my cluster ID. That was easy.
Mhmm.
Okay. And then now I need an API
key, so I'm gonna follow the docs for
that too.
Nice and easy as well.
Perfect.
Alright.
Should I clone the
demo repository?
Yeah. Please do.
Select.
Does it matter if I pick go or
python?
Nope. Nope. Okay.
I'll do Python because the instructions are Python.
There you go.
Oh, I don't have pet. Okay. We'll do
go.
Alright.
So export my cluster ID.
I'll let that build first.
And, you know, you'll wanna actually modify the
pixel script where we filter on namespace.
So I would just find that in the
HTTP errors dot pixel,
and I would just delete that line that
does that filter.
Right. Okay. Yeah. I can do that.
Okay.
So I need to grab my API key
and then you want me to
modify this.
PxDoc.
There we go.
And can I just use the PR namespace?
Yep. That works. You can also just take
it out altogether and just do a class
namespaces.
Done. Alright. So I'm assuming I have to
do a go build again. I'm assuming that's
maybe templated in somewhere.
It's I I don't think so. Think you
can just do go run.
And
all I need now is a Slack bot
token.
Yes. I'm about to send that to you.
But first, I'm gonna create the channel.
Mhmm.
Oh, I'm being mocked again by Noel. Come
on, Noel. Be nice to me. I
am always flashing API tokens on this show.
That's true. But I always delete them straight
after. I promise.
Okay and then once we have our Slackbot
token we're gonna do a go run Slackbot.
And that's us. Yep. Easy. Okay.
Okay. I'm gonna add you
and I'm going to
invite the bot.
Okay. I see Pixie alerting
added to the channel.
Okay. I'm sending you the code over DM.
Thank you. Alright.
So you're happy for me to share the
Pixie test Pixie alerting channel on the stream?
Mhmm.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh, actually, one more thing. We have to
edit the channel
in the script itself in the code because
it actually but but you do export first.
Do the export first.
Okay. I'll do that over here so people
don't see that.
Okay. And then we wanna modify our pixel
script.
Oh, you did that, so that's great.
Okay. And then could we also modify the
function?
It's not in the script, actually. It's in
the
so if you do Oh, Slack button. Oh,
don't open the binary. There we go. Yeah.
So now we're gonna just
yeah. So just change that. I named it
test Pixie alerting.
So we're gonna just
yeah. Great.
So let's try go run. Let's see if
it works.
Yeah. We we did everything there.
I think so.
Hey. It works.
You can maybe just show the Slack.
Oh, look at that.
So Pixie Alerting sent us a message telling
us that we had four x x spikes
in the last five minutes.
Mhmm.
And you can, you know, obviously,
you know, make it more conditional and things
like that or run a different script, but,
you know, we just wanted to kind of
set up the full end to end thing
for people with an easy to use example
that they can then customize to their case.
Okay. So I mean, that's the exact
thing that we discovered with my core DNS.
So was that just complete serendipity that that's
what the alerting script was set up to
be? I think a lot of people are
interested in HTTP
errors. Alright. Okay. So I would say it's
serendipitous,
but I would also say that,
you know, we try to target a common
use case.
Okay.
Are you happy for us just to kinda
take a look at that script and actually
see
what we have here? Let's do it. Yep.
Okay. So
we've got an import p x. I'm assuming
that's just our our Pixie data frame integration
thing.
Yeah.
That's basically the module that we, you know,
provide.
Okay. The table is the HTTP events. So
how would I find what that table is
from my Pixie UI?
Like if I've got data that I wanna
start writing my own Pixie script from or
would I just copy it?
Like, are you saying that like could you
just copy the script itself?
Yeah. I was curious how did I know
how do I know what tables I have
available?
Oh, okay. Here. Let's scroll up
and we're gonna exit out of this one
if that's okay and go to PX slash
schema.
I see you already scrolled up. Was the
one scrolled down. So,
in here, what you can see is all
the different tables in Pixie,
and the description of what they do. And
then in the next table, you can see
all the different columns they have
and what you can find out about them.
Okay. There we go. So that's how I
discover tables and columns that are available for
me to put in my script. Okay. Got
it. Yeah. Because that's not something you could
just infer. We have to document that.
I mean, it is documented but we also
want it to be programmatically
generated as well.
Yeah. That makes sense. Okay. So much like
the web UI, we've got our start time
here.
Now
we're looking for greater than 400 again. That
was just complete
luck that we happened to have the same
query but like you said, it's a common
use case. It makes sense. Yeah.
Now.
I promise it was legitimately already that way
for months. Okay,
so now we're pulling things from our data
frame context and to the top level data
frame. Assume that's just because we want access
to the namespace in the service and the
data that we're working with
then we have our group by service
aggregating
the error count and total request count.
Mhmm. Okay.
And then we get PX display.
What does PX display do? Is that can
I tweak that to display different visualizations?
Yeah. So
basically, the way you can think of it
is there's two ways to write a pixel
spread.
The first is with the VizSpec, which is
what you see if you want fancy charts
and things like that.
But the second is if you're lazy like
me and you just wanna produce a bunch
of tables,
you can use this way. And in this
way, we'll basically basically say that anything you
call p x dot display on will just
be outputted.
Got it. Okay.
Now
I I I could just run this in
the browser to like get live feedback into
what I'm doing and then
move it into like the Go tooling and
do things that way so like the UI
would be a good way to build these
out and then I could put them into
other tooling, is that what you you yeah.
Okay. I'm glad I I understand that then.
And now with regards to the Go code
here,
is this just using the Pixie API to
be able to coordinate setting up the alert
and then
publish to
Slack?
Mhmm. Okay. So the Slack alerting code isn't
something that's available and like the the PX
module.
It's just it's just regular go code.
Okay. That's right. That's right. Because the pixel
scripts, you know, that's for clearing data. And
then because of the API,
you can embed those results into whatever control
flow logic you want.
Okay. The the full picture now is starting
to cement in my mind. So I've got
Yeah. Yeah. I've got pixel. I can create
a data. I could build my visualizations,
and then we've got to go into Python
SDKs if I wanna be able to take
that tool into my own infrastructure,
where I can do alerts and a whole
bunch of other things.
Mez? Yeah. Here here's something quick we could
do actually. K. Let's just run that pixel
script with the CLI just so you can
show the interoperability.
Mhmm. If you just do p x run
and then dash f to save file
and then HTTP errors, it will just run
and produce the results in the CLI.
Oh, I changed directory, so I need to
Oh, okay.
Pixie one
cube.
Nice.
So that can be another way to iterate
on it. And we have a I would
compare another version of the or another command
in CLI that's like I would compare it
to, like, k nines where it's, like, more
interactive and you can, like, switch scripts and
drill down easily.
But just for the purpose of this, it
was just easy to do PX run.
And the one I'm referring to is PX
live.
So you wanna do control k,
and then just select a script. That's a
good one.
But any of them honestly. Yeah. That's good.
Oh, nice.
Alright. I'm running out of adjectives for being
impressed here. You're gonna have to slow down.
Yeah. I I I love that I can
work
in a pretty feature rich way from the
command line or the UI or even from
the SDKs
like, you know, as a as a developer
just having those availabilities to me and being
able to work and what works best for
me or my team, my organization.
Yeah. This is just pretty well rounded. I'm
really impressed with this. How is this just
a startup? I don't get it.
It feels more mature than that.
Well, I mean, you know, we're no longer
a startup. We're now a part of New
Relic which is great.
But yeah, when we were acquired we were
I think 10 or 12 people. So,
you know, we're just really passionate about making
this a great experience for developers like us
is what I would say. Yeah. Normally when
I have, you know, companies that are relatively
new, they're like, okay, it's like, don't click
on this and don't run this and don't
notice this and everything we've done here has
just worked right out of the box. So
very
nice. Okay.
I I'm I'm guessing I don't know. Have
we taken a look at most of the
functionality or is there anything else you would
like us to look at before we wrap
up for today?
You know, I could go on and on
but I think that, you know, for the
benefit of the audience,
we could we could call here and we
can just say that anyone who's interested in
learning more should check out our docs or
our GitHub repo.
You know, please file issues for problems that
you see, and we'd also love for people
to join our Slack community.
Awesome. Yeah. I will make sure there is
a a link to the Slack community and
the show notes. It's also available on the
Pixie website.
Yeah. You should all just definitely go check
it out. You've seen now in the last
hour how easy that was to get started
and the features just keep coming.
We got one question in the chat but
I think we already answered it but I'll
do it again just in case Bob didn't
miss the start But can the whole stack
be self hosted? And if not, is it
on the road map?
Yeah. Love to emphasize this.
Pixie is entirely open sourced.
So even though we went with the free
hosted option today, you can entirely self host
it and,
you know, the instructions for that are in
our docs or you can check out our
GitHub repo to learn more about how to
do that.
Awesome.
Alright. Thank you very much, Natalie. That was
a great tour of Pixie. There was a
lot to love there. Definitely gonna be kicking
the tires on this more with some real
clusters. I just wanted to thank you for
taking the time out of your day for
for guiding us through this and sharing your
knowledge with us. It was an absolute pleasure.
Yeah. It was really great, you know, diving
into it with you as well. It's always
fun to see it from a new perspective,
like from someone who hasn't looked at it
before because I look at it all day.
So
Alright. Well, thank you again. Have a wonderful
day and I'll speak to you again soon.
Yeah. Thank you so much. Alright. Thanks. Bye.